so the manipulation of the body politic
it's about you it's about mobilizing
people against people like you if you
disagree and i'm again i'm not talking
about if you're conservative
i'm talking about if you dissent from
the local orthodoxy in any way
okay and you think you're safe if you're
on if you're a liberal if you agree with
the left on some of their policy
priorities you think you're safe you're
not you're not safe for one
moment in time the minute you become
inconvenient they run you over so here's
the thing about the left
if you are a normal human being then
generally you're a little uncomfortable
about the idea of the mob but you like
people individually right you like
people on an individual level you want
those people to be treated decently
but the idea of the mob you know the
idea of the people collectively being
the big deciders
that's a little bit uncomfortable that's
why we like checks and balances in the
united states
if you are on the left they love
quote-unquote the people but they hate
individuals and if you are in their way
they will
run you over as though they're in a ford
f-150 truck and you are just standing
out there in their way that is that is
all that the left is i mean
the left is just a machine for running
people over in their pursuit of utopia
okay so if you believe as a is a
good-hearted liberal who just disagrees
with me about tax rates and about
abortion and
about key issues right we can have those
key disagreements but if you agree with
me about individual rights
like freedom of speech and the ability
to disseminate information and have
discussions with people across the other
side of the aisle
then you're gonna have to make a
decision do you wish to move along
with the woke left because you agree
with them on policy
and run over rights in the process or do
you wish to preserve rights and maybe
it'll make it a little bit tougher for
you to convince people
of your political agenda but at least
you'll have preserved the rights that's
the decision that's going to be up to
people who are liberals but not leftists
okay that's your choice not up to me
it's up to you okay because
they're coming for everyone okay i'm
gonna give you an example it doesn't
matter how nice you are there's a
perfect example of individuals not
mattering all that matters
here's the thing on the left what they
actually believe is that your belief
system
it's so weird they believe that your
belief system is what makes you good or
bad
you can be a perfectly crappy human
being but if you believe the right
things this makes you a good human being
normal people believe that it's the
things you do on a daily basis that make
you a good human being
it's your aspiration to continue to do
more good things on a daily basis that's
what makes you
a good human being folks on the left on
the hard left
they believe that you can be the nicest
person in the world but if you believe
the wrong things they will run you over
so here's a perfect example this this
column struck me so hard over the
weekend
it's a piece by a woman named virginia
heffernan a virginia heffernan
writing for the los angeles times it's
called what can you do
about the trumpets next door quote oh
heck no
the trump lights next door to our
pandemic getaway who seem as devoted to
the ex-president as you can get without
being
queue fans just plowed our driveway
without being asked and did a great job
how am i going to resist demands for
unity in the face of this act of
aggressive niceness
on some level of course i realize i owe
them things
and man it really looks like the guy
back dragged the driveway like a pro but
how much
thanks these neighbors are staunch
partisans of blue lives
and there aren't a lot of anything other
than white lives in this neighborhood oh
my god they like cops
holy they like cops this is also kind of
weird
back in the city people don't sweep up
other people's walkways for nothing
maybe it's like what eddie murphy
discovered in that old saturday night
live sketch white like me
he goes undercover in white makeup and
finds that when white people are moving
among their own they pop free champagne
and live the high life as murphy puts it
slowly i began to realize that when
white people are alone
they give things to each other for free
hezbollah the shiite islamist political
party in lebanon
also gives things away for free the
favors hezbollah does for people in the
cities
tyr and sidon probably don't involve
snowplows but like other mafias
hezbollah tends to atone the shiite sick
elderly and hungry
they offer protection and hospitality
and win loyalty that way and they also
demand devotion to their brutal us
versus them anti-sunni cause
some of us are family the favor say the
rest are infidels the same is true with
louis farrakhan who currently helms the
nation of islam this person is crazy
this person needs to be in a rubber room
like immediately like put this person in
a straitjacket and drag them to the
hoohoo house
this is like while the southern poverty
law center classifies him as a dangerous
anti-semite much of his flock says he's
just a little screwy and unfailingly
magnanimous to them
when someone helps you when you're down
or snowden it's almost impossible to
regard them as a blight on the world
in fact you're more likely to be
overwhelmed with gratitude and convinced
of the person's inherent goodness
you might end up like the upper class
family i stayed with in france as a
teenager
they did not attend a citywide
celebration for the 100th birthday of
charles de gaulle the war hero who
orchestrated the liberation of his
country from nazi germany in 1944.
they did have several portraits of
philippe petain nazi collaborator on
their wall
when i screwed up the courage to ask how
it was for them during the occupation
the lady of the house replied we were
happy because the nazis were very pulse
i didn't know the word so i excused
myself to consult a french english
dictionary i was in tears when i found
the entry
polite so when i accept generosity from
my pandemic neighbors acknowledging the
legitimate kindness with a wave or a
plate of cookies
am i also sealing us in as fellow
travelers
are very polished to each other but not
so much to them now let it be said
there are certain perspectives on the
world that can actually make you a bad
person right if you believe
that slavery is a good idea this can
make you a bad person if you believe
in the murder of all members of x group
this can make you a bad person but she
is currently likening
a trump supporter who plowed her
driveway for her
to hezbollah louis farrakhan
and the nazis i have a feeling that this
person's belief are making her an actual
honest-to-goodness in
daily deed bad person as this person
says loving your neighbor is evidently
much easier when your neighborhood is
full of people just like you i love that
she's just throwing it like how did she
know
if she'd if she were black how does she
know the neighbors wouldn't come over
and plow the driveway
does she know that she has no evidence
of that whatsoever other than her own
unjustified moral superiority and belief
that her next-door neighbors for being
trump supporters must be vicious nazi
racists who would only do this for a
person living in a store who's white
just thrusting that on them
she doesn't know them at all literally
the only thing the only two things she
knows about them
are that they're nice and plowed her
driveway for her did her favor and
they voted for trump so instead of her
saying to herself it's
instead of saying to herself you know
maybe it's possible that some trump
supporters are nice people
and i've miscast and mischaracterized
many trump supporters and their belief
systems
instead of her thinking that it's no it
must be they who are wrong
it must be i whim the morally wonderful
one
okay i don't care what dirt this person
lives on with me
we ain't in the same country if she like
that that's this is wild stuff
she says what do we do about the trump
bites around us like representative
alexander ocasio-cortez who spoke
eloquently this week
about her terrifying experience during
the insurrection at the capitol on
january 6th
americans are expected to forgive and
forget before we've even stitched up our
wounds
or gotten our vaccines against the
pandemic that former president trump
utterly failed to mitigate
my neighbors supported a man who showed
near murderous contempt for the majority
of americans
they kept him in business with their
support but
the plowing on january 6th after the
insurrection senator ben sasse issued an
awesome plea for all americans to love
their neighbors
at the time i seethed the capital hadn't
just desecrated but maybe my neighbor
heard sass and was determined to make a
bid for reconciliation
so here is my response to the plowed
driveway for now politely but not
profusely i'll acknowledge
the sassy and move with a wave and a
thanks a minimal start on building back
trust
i'm not ready to knock on the door with
a covered dish yet
i also can't give my neighbors
absolution it's not mine to give nobody
asked you for absolution you crazy
person
nobody at what what are you absolving
them of is it a nice thing for you and
have different
views on politics and your answer is
they're asking you for absolution but
you can't give it
honestly if i were these people's name
if i was this lady's neighbor and i read
this piece
i would take my snow cloud i would go
out into the street i'd gather as much
snow as humanly possible and dump it
directly on her driveway
i'd pile that sucker like eight feet
high and she can dig that
she can dig that out with a with a
trowel for all i care
what a nasty piece of goods seriously
but this is the work
do you feel the unity do you feel it i
feel the unity and i especially feel the
unity
when elise in our society mirror this
perspective and then mobilize the levers
of power in order to push forward this
perspective such that if you disagree
with them it's because you just want to
break the country
i love this she says i can offer a
standing invitation to make amends not
with a snowplow but by recognizing the
truth about the trump administration and
more important
by working for justice for all those
whom the administration harmed
so in other words i don't care that you
did a nice thing for me only when you
bow before zod only when you agree with
me
will you be deemed one of the morally
elect
okay this is the woke priesthood at work
so which side you want to be on liberals
this is my question on the other side of
virginia heffernan you sound like
somebody that you want to live next door
to
or would you like to live in the same
neighborhood as the trump supporter who
disagrees with you
on tax rates and immigration but also
might plow your driveway once in a while
and recognizes that you actually
are brothers in arms against many of the
myriad ills that
that wreck countries all over the world
historically
there can be no unity with this there
can't and if people who agree with this
sort of stuff control the levers of
power
there will not be any unity it's just
going to get worse
it's just going to be worse from here on
in i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content